Nikola slapshot is a is an author
journalist and an online content
consultant he has earned a degree in
politics from the University of York a
former senior editor at The Daily Beast
mr. Webb shot has served as New York
bureau chief and editor of the Saturday
edition of The Times of London business
columnist for The Sunday Telegraph and
founding editor of The Times Magazine as
political editor of The Observer he
covered Margaret Thatcher's final years
in office mr. Webb shot appears
regularly on CNN MSNBC PBS and Fox News
he is the author of numerous books
including Thatcher
one of the first biographies of Margaret
Thatcher Peter O'Toole a biography
Ronald Reagan and Margaret Thatcher a
political marriage Carol read a
biography and most recently Keynes Hayek
the clash that defined modern economics
please join me in welcoming our speaker
nicholas pop shot
[Applause]
good evening it's very good to be here
in Hillsdale
I must say I've des reputation is
enormous
but I had not guessed how beautiful it
was going to be what a lovely campus you
are so privileged it's a great great
treat to be here and particularly in
such a strange week as it's turned out
so this is this is sort of a perfect cap
as far as I'm concerned on the end of I
think it's true for all of us one of the
most extraordinary weeks in our
lifetimes politically and let's see
economically to well I think is the mic
on at the back do I do this oh I can
hear myself man that must be good ok I'm
sorry it's you want me to repeat what I
just said I just said the tills day was
a wonderful place and there's been a
terrible week ok so here we are to talk
about it first of all I'm not sure who
made up the title but I'd like to thank
them I am asked endlessly to talk about
Keynes and Hayek and it took Hillsdale
to say that I should have talked about
Hayek and Keynes
[Applause]
and that's entirely worthwhile I have
enormous admiration for Friedrich Hayek
anybody who's looked at is long and
extraordinary career will understand
that he was a man of exceptional
abilities and mind you I also have
extraordinary time for John Maynard
Keynes which might not be shared with
everybody in this room but there's no
doubt that John Maynard Keynes was an
extraordinary person in terms of the
history of the 20th century leaving
Churchill aside I don't think anyone
except for Keynes did more to change the
world it might be good or bad but he
changed the world in a way that very few
original thinkers did and as a
biographer one of the reasons that I'm
delighted with this story
a powerful fact that I'm a political
economist so this stuff is obsessed me
forever is that if you were to write the
story of Einstein you wouldn't be able
to put him in a room with Isaac Newton
the big change the big paradigm shift
couldn't be done because the two people
weren't there but in this case this is a
fascinating story this is a story about
how John Maynard Keynes was on the brink
of bringing forth his general theory
which would transform economics it would
invent effectively macroeconomics and
totally changed the relationship between
governments and the economy and the
people they governed and he was on the
edge of this extraordinary paradigm
shift in economics and there was a late
break when Friedrich Hayek from Austria
came in order to say before you get too
deep into this let me give you some
warnings and that was an extraordinary
act of courage in a way but it was also
of course an act of career advancement I
don't think that anyone would doubt that
Friedrich Hayek always had his eye on
the main chance and why not he was
brought up in Austria of course that's
why it's called the Austrian school von
Mises and so on they were all genuine
Austrians they lived in Vienna and he
was one year more than the century so
he's born in 1899 he had a not very good
Great War as most Germans of Austrians
didn't actually as it turns out because
they were on the losing side but he he
was active in the war and he fought on
the Italian front and Dede almost hanged
himself he was this is the days this is
before satellite technology and so on
this is when you send a guy up on a
balloon with binoculars to see what the
enemy is doing and they were bringing
him down a bit fast because they'd
started bombarding the balloon and he
jumped out early but he kept his
headphones on and he nearly strangled
himself in which case this lecture would
never have happened at his person anyway
happily happily you survived but he was
he was an ambitious fellow and he was a
bit well you find it very difficult to
guide himself he was for instance
interested in first of all we should say
this his his parents were academics not
great academics but they were academics
and he thought he had a life in academia
particularly in economics he thought but
he wasn't quite sure which direction to
move in and then circumstances really
introduced him to something which was
became his life's obsession really and
that is that when Germany and the
austro-hungarians lost World War 1 and
there both of their empires collapsed
austria-hungary divided into its
constituent parts which included all the
bits and pieces of Serbia and Kosovo and
so on but also Austria and Hungary were
now a separate and like many countries
in the immediate aftermath of World
one the economy was shot this was now a
new state unit it didn't it was that
meant to be the head of a big vast
sprawling trade empire and that was just
the head people didn't make anything
anymore
if you will excuse a quote and he was
interested in just what was happening to
his country inflation had gone crazy I
mean this is absolutely at the time when
people turned up with wheelbarrows in
order to take their cash home
you could hear apparently a sort of 2:00
in the morning if you put your ear out
of your window you lived in central
Vienna you could hear the printing
presses printing the money it was such
dire state now he fell in with and good
luck for him he fell in with Ludwig von
Mises who as we know from Israel's good
talk this afternoon von Mises actually
is the key to the Austrian school it's
all in von Mises actually and almost
everything apart from the late work of
Hayek we're moved into political
philosophy but when it comes to
economics really von Mises is the boy
but Hayek was keen to stretch his legs
he was keen to move outside of Vienna
and he decided to engage the most famous
economists of the time who was John
Maynard Keynes no who was John Maynard
Keynes do you ask
well he's 16 years older than Hayek so
he is born whatever 1899 minus 16 is 83
and he was a wunderkind to use the
Austrian expression he was like as a
young man he was recruited into the
Treasury the British Treasury where his
amazingly agile inventive mind allowed
him to do instantly amazingly important
work so before world one where
even started john maynard keynes came to
Wall Street and raised the money and he
didn't just borrow it on behalf of
Britain he borrowed it on behalf of
France and Italy fighting against
Germany austro-hungary an extraordinary
responsibility for a man in his twenties
it's just beyond belief and then when
the war came to an end he was drafted in
to be part of that huge circus which
American historians will know all about
which is the preparations for the Treaty
of Versailles and rana maynard keynes
part of the british treasury team
visiting that extraordinary drawing-room
where woodrow wilson everyday brought in
all of the victors together to work out
what to do with the wretched Germans and
the Austrians and John Maynard Keynes
worked out that actually what they
wanted to do is punish the Germans and
that meant turning Germany more or less
into an agricultural community so it
would never again way to war on France
and on Italy and Keynes thought this was
going to go terribly wrong and he wrote
first of all he fretted he almost had a
nervous breakdown
he went home and in a very short time he
wrote a book which would transform him
and it turns out the post-war world
which was called the economic
consequences of the peace and in that he
predicted that if you punished Germany
and austria-hungary as the Allies wanted
to do then what you would do was to
store up a range of anger and resentment
against the Allies that would spill
eventually first of all it would be
catastrophic people would be going
hungry people there would be mass
unemployment and that German Austrian
population would fall victim to the
first dictator who stuck his head above
the parapet and said come this way I've
got a solution to it he went out of his
way actually to say how Austria was
particularly badly treated and how there
were women and children who were being
starved there which Hayek must have
taken some notice on and then
Kayne's started thinking what happened
in britain was and it's rather like
what's happened after the brexit
actually at the beginning of the war the
pound to the dollar was something like
480 and then at the end of the war it
was about 360 and what the government in
its wisdom decided to do was to restore
the value of the pan to its pre-war
level and you don't have to be amazingly
smart at economics to work out that
actually if you've got very high prices
for all of your goods your exports
collapse and that's what happened there
was mass unemployment throughout the 20s
when America was enjoying an enormous
boom the Roaring Twenties flappers the
Charleston all that stuff you were going
like a fair here meanwhile in Britain
everybody was on the bread line there
were long marches from the north of
England to the south and so on there was
turmoil and he got to thinking that this
can't be quite right he would by the way
he wasn't an economist at all keynes he
was a mathematician which is no bad
thing when it comes to working out
economics today and he decided that
something should be done about it and he
got to thinking first of all he was
amazingly eloquent he would work for the
Daily Mail which is a tabloid newspaper
for middle middle people and he would
write for Vanity Fair and he would write
for London Times which was for the
ruling people he could write in any
direction he wanted to make his argument
and what he said was if these people are
by government decision of the currency
out of work then the government ought to
find them work to do and this was
revolutionary in those times
well Hayek read a great deal of this his
English was rather poor but he seemed to
have reading English like everybody it
does you have a language is easier to
read than it is to speak and he read a
lot of Keynes
and so in 1927 this is the beginning of
what was to turn out to be an
extraordinary 20 year long
who's gonna call it friendship it's
there's no such a word as frenemy ship
it's you know it's bit of both like
neither one nor the other in 1927 he out
of the blue this is some kid in Austria
wrote a postcards to John Maynard Keynes
already a world celebrity saying I
wonder whether you have a copy of
mathematical psychics an essay on the
application of mathematics to the moral
sciences
well as it turned out as we might
understand Keynes didn't have one of
those but he was so well brought up he
wrote a letter to Hayek and said sorry
haven't got a copy of that but thanks
for asking
that letter is Knightly found in the
Hoover Institution I don't think they
make as much of it as they should it
ought to be actually framed and there as
you go in the lobby but anyway that was
the beginning of what was to turn out to
be an extraordinary encounter and duel
which really set the tone for everything
that's happened since in terms of even
today the sort of arguments we have
about whether governments should
intervene or not so that was 1927 1928
he was invited to London by a man called
Lionel Robbins he was the full professor
of economics age 31 of the London School
of Economics and bright fellow and he
decided that with Keynes in Cambridge in
Cambridge being the place for economics
before Keynes there was a man called
after P gu who was extraordinary his
professor of economics and before him
was a guy called Marshall and Marshall
wrote the book I mean you know that was
the textbook Marshall was everything
about economics until Keynes came and
upset his fun and so Hayek was invited
by the LSE in order to really set up a
rival to Keynes
Cambridge Keynes in Cambridge and it
seemed a good idea as far as robbins was
concerned here's this great boom going
on in Cambridge if we only set ourselves
up as a rival we'd all do very well out
of it and yeah it's true that robbins
thought of calling von Mises which would
have been
the top star of Austrian economics that
I think as you might have learned from
izi von mises was an awkward cast to put
it mildly he he was troublesome he was
had a foul temper and he was awkward and
he was also a bit old and grand as far
as he was concerned he was a big deal
and the last thing he needed was to go
to London in order to become a junior
professor in order to take on someone
who didn't believe in at all but Hayek
said I'll do it harder and this is
typical drag instead of going to the LSE
he went straight to Cambridge where he
met with a group of people who were to
vote it decays I mean Katie it's
difficult to explain the charm of Cannes
Cannes was so eloquent so extraordinary
he people who followed him just like
disciples like devotees and there was a
group of them called the Cambridge
circus and they were all the kids really
who followed Keynes and Hayek came to
explain what Austrian economics was all
about and he got his blackboard and his
chalk and he started writing diagrams
and so on and it totally flummoxed them
and got any idea at all in fact one of
them one of them the man if you're
interested in economics he's the man who
actually proved that there was such a
thing as a multiplier that is if you
spend a pound it's worth far more than a
pen by the time the pound is finished
because if you give the pound to the
butcher the butcher buys candles from
the candlestick maker candlestick maker
buys so I need sew on the money goes dad
and this man called car ended up asking
hiya Chris question is it your view that
if I went out tomorrow and bought a new
overcoat that would increase
unemployment and Hayek said yes but it
would take a very long time
mathematically to explain my argument
why that is the case I must say to this
day I can't imagine the circumstances in
which that would be the case but he did
so
19:31 this is three years later Robin
says we want this guy to be a professor
at the LSE and all he has to do is give
four lectures on Austrian economics and
he's in and that's what he did I have
given a lecture in the very lecture hall
that Hayek gave and the LSE and I must
say it's rather extraordinary to stand
there imagining as you know Austrian
economics gets a sort of mixed press and
even at the LSE a wasn't considered
really a hot thing to do for four nights
in a row
so Robins drafted a sort of three-line
whip saying you will be there and so
they all came and he was indeed given
the post so there he was the first job
that Lionel Robbins got got him to do
was to review a book by john maynard
keynes which he would imaginal be a bit
inflammatory which it was the idea of
course and Hayek was delighted with this
was to actually snag Keynes's attention
and actually get him embroiled in an
argument about his views about spending
borrowing government money and spending
it on him in order to put people back to
work and that's therefore he was given
the latest book by Keynes to review well
Hayek now it's true to say that Hayek
says I told you his English wasn't too
good he could be a little brisk and
brusque to put it mildly he wasn't quite
as bad as von Mises probably in
temperament but he was pretty tough and
he reviewed a book which actually no one
has read ever since an essay by Kane
said know it even even Keynes when he
wrote it he said I don't really agree
with this any more this is you know two
years ago thinking I've moved beyond
this which is one of the problems he got
when Hayek took it very seriously and
started taking it to bits in the most
rude fashion possible and well Keynes
never never one to turn down a fight
instantly rotary passed and he was as
rude as Hayek was and then that's
economically this is September 1930
three months later they put in Keynes's
were passed followed by the second
episode of Hayek's assault on the book
which was even ruder saying you don't
answer any of the questions in Europe
Aston ba ba ba ba ba ba he got to the
stage of the P gu or I mentioned before
the Cambridge economics person said this
is sounding like Kilkenny cats fighting
with each other
please stop it you're giving economics a
bad name but you didn't stop them they
they carried on even on Christmas Day
can you imagine this I mean this is a
days of I'm not sure what the American
post office is like well actually I know
exactly what the post office is like
well I can assure you that in even in
Britain in 1931 on Christmas Day free
deliveries that's an extraordinary thing
they three two-and froze and it went on
into January and then finally they sort
of gave up on it the actual details of
the argument is not really very
illuminating in fact he gives you a
headache if you try to understand what
they were arguing about but the
principle was important Hayek is now in
London and he's in the right place
because Keynes in the end said do I done
enough with this Hayek guy there might
be something in it but who can tell in
anyway I've got stuff to do because what
he was doing was preparing the full
detail of the general theory which was
the thing which was going to transform
economics which was finished in 1935 and
published in 1936 so they're sort of
four or five year period when it came to
the publication of the general theory
Hayek of course was the obvious person
to come out and take it a bit why not
but that's not the way it worked out in
economic at the LSE they actually chose
someone else entirely they chose P GU
who himself had been offended by what
Keynes was suggesting and they thought
that P gu was actually just a better
counter than Hayek at this time Hayek
meanwhile had said to Keynes you have an
economics journal I wonder whether you
would allow me to write
of your general theory now Keynes one of
the many things about Keynes was he was
amazingly good at the market he was
fantastic at drumming up business he
knew when controversy would sell a book
he was anxious he had actually sent
proofs of the general theory to Hayek on
the hope that Hayek would take it up and
cause a fuss and he went and didn't
happen just didn't happen so then it was
thought that maybe it was because Hayek
was writing a book which was going to be
his equivalent of the general theory but
even that got bogged down there's a sort
of pathetic note he sends to a friend at
one stage saying I'm bogged down in
Chapter six
and that's where sort of it's stuck
however the the the key arguments would
come out eventually and Hayek would be
able to take him on but it meant that
there was a sort of resolution of the
two of them having been the bitterest
enemies over an intellectual pursuit it
turned out then that Hayek didn't return
to Austria in 1938 when Hitler invaded
with the angelus he decided that he
would become a Brit and he stayed on at
the LSE and in 1940 in the Blitz the LSE
was bombed and the University had to
move and they found that there was a
College in Cambridge Peterhouse which
was full of young undergraduate men and
they'd all gone off to the war so it was
mostly empty so the Elysee moved
wholesale there this is typical of
Keynes said Keynes called up Hayek and
said Friedrich the architecture of Peter
house is particularly poor let me find
use in the space in King's College next
to me so he invited his nemesis his arch
enemy to become his colleague and
throughout the war years they would dine
on a regular basis they didn't talk
about economics much as you might
imagine but they they both collected old
economics books
first editions of economics tracts and
things like that and they got on very
well and their wives got on very well
too so altogether it was very happy I
opened my book with an extraordinary
event where they both found themselves
on the roster for defending King's
College Chapel which is I don't know
ever been to Cambridge is the most
beautiful soaring English perpendicular
church architecture they were both sat
or stood on the roof with brooms and
shovels against the German bombs
incendiary bombs that were being bombed
on Cambridge turned out that the RAF had
been bombing all of the places where the
u-boats were holed up in the Baltic
States they were all medieval towns and
so in order to get at the u-boats you
had to destroy a medieval town and there
was a German this is a typical piece of
sort of German efficiency well if
they're going to destroy our medieval
towns we're going to destroy their
medieval towns even though there was
nothing military in most of them
certainly nothing in Cambridge but they
sent the the bombs over in order to
teach Britain a lesson and that's where
these two guys it's like the beginning
of a movie isn't it kayak and canes
stood there with planes raining overhead
if Hayek didn't make any great progress
when it came to economics he did
actually understand what the outcome
would be if people followed Keynes's
advice and started spending money they
didn't have in order to produce jobs
that weren't there and he came to the
conclusion it was rather more than
economic efficiency which he thought was
hopeless so in brief the Hayekian
argument is that if you deliberately
encourage the wrong sort of industries
to over produce all you will end up is a
lot of unsold goods and a lot of
factories in the wrong place making the
wrong sorts of things and that was the
natural a problem because no-one was as
wise as the market in allocating
resources and I now say that it's a
truism it's rather didn't hard to deny
Keynes was on a sort of different level
he was talking about he constantly he
and Hayek constantly were worried about
the business cycle if you remember that
clash was in 1931 this is at the time of
the Great Depression these are now there
are any millions of unemployed in
Britain there are tens of millions of
unemployed in in America - and the
obvious thing for someone like Roosevelt
to do and I did it purely in ignorance
he thought we should just employ some
people let's get some ideas together and
let's just let's get the states nor the
state the federal government to employ
people but it wasn't thought through
what Keynes did was actually work out an
economic logic which suggested that one
of the reasons that you could not have a
bottom of a business cycle is that
demand has collapsed and if you borrowed
and filled up the bottom of that but
most importantly if you paid back the
loans that you've taken out at the
bottom of the business cycle at the top
of the business cycle then you wouldn't
get the sharp swings
up and down which all business cycles up
until then at least haddad free [ __ ]
Hayek brought these ideas together he
wasn't able to express himself very
clearly it's true in economics and in
terms of country Keynes but he did write
the book for which everybody remembers
him which is the road to serfdom and he
wrote that in 1944 March 1944 it was
published
they were very foolish by the way the
British government he was a person who
spoke fluent German was absolutely on
the side of the Allies he was a proper
Democrat and he would have been
amazingly useful to the war effort but
although he volunteered he wasn't
allowed to because he was a natural-born
Austrian and he was actually jolly lucky
not to rather like the Japanese to have
been interned as all sorts of other
young colonists from Italy and saw like
piero sraffa was interned in the isle of
man so he was lucky to escape there but
at the same time he found himself
kicking his heels and he started it
would came obvious after 1941 as soon as
the Americans came into the war that the
the economic might of the United States
and their manpower and the general drive
would mean that Hitler and Mussolini and
Japan would lose so in which case he
turned his mind to what the post-war
world would be like and so he in the
road to serfdom if I can find the right
and then I can't fight it deep throat
septum is a really snappy good selling
title the original one was not put in
madly when I can't fight Overland I
might find it a bit later on what he
said was he was the first person really
to confront those conventional thinkers
who thought that somehow the communism
was on the left and that fascism was on
the right he said no no they're based in
exactly the same place and that's
because they have ignore what the free
market they've ignored the role of
prices and they have intervened they
have planned that's the problem with
both Stalin and both Hitler they plan
every element of a country's life and
individualism is chased out and really
the road to serfdom says no more than we
should be very careful when we look at
the post-war world and we look how well
the governments have managed to manage
the economy and manage the war to think
that somehow a very large role for the
government should be maintained once
peace arrives the Keynesian z' by this
time Keynes had taken over by the way
American economics were together
particularly in Harvard but Keynes just
swept the New Deal because it provided a
justification for the sorts of things
they were doing and made them a little
smarter so d get this to explain it
properly so Hayek argued in road to
serfdom that we should he had to be a
bit careful about the Russians cuz they
were our allies still in 1945 but
knowing that the Nazis had gone he tried
to dress it up and it's I sure you've
all read it all I can ask is that you
read it again because you will have
missed out a lot of stuff it's a very
short book he wasn't served very well
Reader's Digest bought the rights to it
thinking they do immature good
and they sort of put out a 50% addition
which sort of missed more of the
interesting arguments which but it did
make him a great deal of money they sold
more than a million copies in the United
States alone of the Road to Serfdom and
he found himself a great celebrity he
wasn't actually best fitted to be a
celebrity I mean Riz Keynes was sort of
rock and roll he liked all of the
attention and everything else Hayek was
bit embarrassed I mean even in a crowd
this side here he was not very
comfortable with it but it's so very
still it's a very useful piece of work I
was talking at dinner and so I excuse me
a little detour here one of the things
that he said in the road to serfdom is
that there should be a working welfare
state and it should be provided by the
central government if I can find it here
I will read it to you because it's
pretty easy you might think that's sort
of anomalous for Hayek to say such a
thing but remember he came from a
European society where particularly
those Germanic ideas such as Bismarck's
welfare state of being going for good
fifty years before World War two this is
what he wrote in a road serfdom there
can be no doubt that some minimum of
food shelter and clothing sufficient
reserve health and the capacity to work
could be assured to everybody where as
in the case of sickness and accident
neither the desire to avoid such
calamities nor the efforts to overcome
their consequences are as a rule
weakened by the revision of assistance
where a short we deal with generally
insurable risks the case for the state's
helping to organize a comprehensive
system of social insurance is very
strong so there you are food shelter
clothing and health was a prerequisite
as far as Hayek was concerned well now I
have the same to Keynes as Keynes attend
to higher
he sent him some proof copies of the
Road to Serfdom hoping that Keynes would
make a song and dance and say where and
which case help sell the book in Britain
he didn't need it in America as I've
just said that and case was as it was
was amazingly generous but there was
always a bit of a sting in the tail see
if I can find the very piece to have
five says you have to excuse me for
fitting around yet
I'm so sorry
I'm just gonna have to tell you what it
said what he said flex of your very
interesting ideas Friedrich we are all
worried about this we're all right about
the government goodness sake we've just
just fought the Nazis off they were big
government people were frightened to
death of Stalin he's big government
people but what you say is very
interesting because what you say is
actually yes let's have the free market
and let's organize it properly
let's have regulation as you suggest
let's have a referee let's have all the
things that you need to ensure that a
market is fair fair what we call today a
level playing field he said but I notice
that you say that there are some things
which are so important that actually the
government themselves should intervene
in the market and he quoted this bit he
said in which case Friedrich
what I think we're talking about here is
that you and I would probably most
likely agree on those things it's just a
matter of where you draw that line
between government and the market and
once you get into agreeing that that's
the case then actually you're not
providing anything real different at all
what you're just saying is you're
marginally different to me it was a good
argument and it left him Hayek sort of
speechless he didn't know how to respond
to the very final element of Hayek and
Keynes was shortly before Keynes died
when in King's College in the senior
common room he's he did raise the
subject of economics and he said I've
been talking to some of your disciples
and I must say they they're taking your
theory and they're running with it and
they are doing things which are going to
cause enormous trouble I mean they take
this really as a blank check for
governments to do whatever they like and
as as bigger scale as they like and
things are gonna go wrong aren't they
and Payne said I think you might be on
to something
if that were to ever to be the case
don't worry because I will intervene and
it'll take me three months just to turn
around everybody's opinion and then
it'll be fine
well he was dead within three months and
that was that there was there was no
holding anyone back and as we know the
history of the post-world War two world
on both sides of the Atlantic has been
until the mid seventies until inflation
caught up with everybody it has been
Keynesianism
run riot and even presidents like
eisenhower who really didn't believe in
deficit spending on the other hand he
found a very good way through national
defense to set up interested state
highways huge public works program which
passed his defense spending so it didn't
really get into the normal ways but
otherwise every single president
whatever they've said until the
seventies used Keynesianism and the
problem is that the business cycle and
the electoral cycle don't stay in sync
and the result is that if someone is
running a great deficit and they've got
an election coming up they're more
likely to pile on with a little more
spending to make a little more growth
and a little more wealth come election
day and so the the absolute prerequisite
of Keynes's dictum was that you should
pay debt off at the top of the business
cycle was ignored that led to inflation
of a hyper kind at most of you by the
look at it we'll be able to remember the
70s and it really wasn't funny
double-digit inflation was not funny
it's bad for everybody it's particularly
bad for working people who constantly
have to go back to the boss and saying
could you give me another 60% on what I
had last year because the prices have
gone up the person however who cured
that or at least contributed to the
theory which allowed it to be cured was
Hayekian but not so much he was a Milton
Friedman which is actually that subjects
for my next book but what Hayek did
after the war after the death of Keynes
was set up the Mont Pelerin Society and
he said he brought together a whole
bunch of maverick conservatives and
libertarians
and colonists and she took them
literally up a mountain in Switzerland
and he gave them a lecture and he said
look the left in the past has had all
the running it has all the great ideas
it has the romantic notions it has the
big utopian future everybody's
constantly looking forward to you know
the the progressive age when everybody
will be drinking milk and honey and you
know listening to opera all day and
everything and it'll be just a sublime
and nobody asked to any work and that's
what conservatives need and we need to
find that philosophy and then we can
make takers years it could take us 20
years well it actually took them 30
years before they really made any
progress and that was because of
actually the the person who did it more
than anywhere else actually with Jimmy
Carter but they were not doesn't quite
fit the story does it Jimmy Carter was
the person who appointed Paul Volcker to
be the head of the Federal Reserve and
he was the person who effectively what
we now call rebooted the economy and
purged the inflation from the system and
then kept spending within limits I think
that Friedman said you could go up to 2%
a years about as much inflation as you
would want in your economy so things
change but the but Friedman actually
wasn't sure I'd want to confuse this too
much but Friedman wasn't an Austrian
although he was amazingly fond of Hayek
and Hayek was used to say that Friedman
and Keynes were closer together than he
was to either of them so I'll leave you
to explore there are extra reading
exactly what those complexities are but
the basic principle of Hayek attempting
to head off before it had even happened
the Keynesian revolution was one of
those gallant efforts probably always
likely to run into the sand it's very
very difficult to actually stand in the
middle of a road when a juggernauts
heading you away which is what Keynes
and Keynesianism was but there's no diet
that he was the person who put down
which allowed 4050 years on a different
way of looking at the economy and one
which we have been in more or less ever
since I'm going to turn it over to
questions but I would just add this
because we are now in a new world since
Tuesday conservatism has meant many
things it has certainly meant in recent
years free trade that's going to be an
interesting battle and the other thing
which is sort of more Keynesian if you
like the president-elect has promised a
trillion dollars worth of spending on
infrastructure projects well that'll
certainly kick the economy alright I
mean I'm sure that John may not cancel
to be applauding in his grave at the
moment but it's it's exactly what the
house leadership of the Senate
leadership of the Republican Party have
tried to prevent happening so we've got
these happy battles to cover the battle
between Keynes and Hayek is not dead and
and if you're interested in the the
actual root of the the economics rather
than the sort of the big picture stuff I
wish you luck because it's not at all
easy it is not at all it really even on
a good day Hayek it can be very
difficult to read
Keynes was easy to read actually
although it's might be worth as a final
thing just reading this Paul Samuelson
who became sort of the Pope of the
Keynesian zs-- of the MIT wrote this
about the general theory and then I'll
take some questions
it's a badly written book poorly
organized its arrogant bad-tempered
polemical and not overly general
generous in its acknowledgments flashes
of intuition intersperse
tedious algebra an awkward definition
suddenly gives way to unforgettable
cadenza when it's finally mastered we
find its analysis to be obvious and at
the same time new in short it's a work
of genius
so there we are now who would like to
set that to set the ball rolling do you
need a mic yes good thank you very much
missing shot mr. option is agreeing to
sign copies of his book Keynes Hayek the
clash that defined modern economics in
the lobby immediately following the
lecture we now have time for a few
questions please raise your hand and the
microphone will be brought to you Thank
You Christian
you said that John Maynard Keynes
experienced in economics but how is it
that he decided to come to the
conclusion that more government
intervention can help spur economic
growth when in which in which history
tell us has time and time and again
throughout history we have been it's
been proven that that does not work in
centrally planned economies how it's
interesting and how far you going back
you know who built the Coliseum did a
lot for growth these it's actually big
large projects traditionally is to boost
growth it's a matter of what they then
do to the economy do they corrupt it so
that you can never win yourself off it
that's what Hayek was worried about if
you spend the amount of money that you
need to spend in order to stop a
recession from happening where does that
money go does it end up in the wrong
places does it end up getting wasted
and I guess the short answer is yes but
I think the Keynes will say yes but that
doesn't matter because in the mean time
you've employed a lot of people they've
all paid taxes you know the the human
spirit has been maintained and all the
rest of it and so it might be worth that
that'll probably get Hayek I must say
was never able to say exactly what would
happen he just said it the world is so
complicated things could go terribly
wrong but I can't tell you exactly what
which is not the strongest of
to something which is promising sort of
heaven on earth Keynes had the easier
thing you've just pushed against an open
door the government's wanted to spend
this money anyway and that's the problem
I guess you know the Keynesian is is too
attractive and too even the
president-elect seems to think so too
you attributed the quashing of inflation
to Jimmy Carter now having bought my
first house in 1978 I can tell you the
interest rate was 11 and a half percent
as I remember Ronald Reagan beat Jimmy
Carter on the basis of the so-called
misery index which was a combination of
inflation and interest rates and it was
horrendous inflation was it must have
been 11 and 12 percent so I was
surprised that you claimed the Jimmy
Carter quashed inflation when if there
is an irony Paul Volcker is credited
with purging inflation from the system
you can't do it overnight Paul Volcker
actually lifelong Democrat I see him
quite often in New York still alive
still fascinating still completely
contrary to his own party when it comes
to economics but he was the guy who
actually insisted that a recession be
introduced that was painful too but
coming out of the recession there was no
inflation left what Reagan did was
confirm that Volcker should stay as the
chairman of the Federal Reserve but
actually you know many of these things
happen in the administration before and
they they don't quite come out so I
think the Carter but by the way
undoubtedly one of America's most
intelligent presidents I don't know
whether you've ever met presidents any
presidents Bill Clinton plaintiff very
intelligent man but artist astonishingly
bright man and I don't know whether he
knew what he was doing but anyway he
should take he should take credit for
were there reasonable objections to
Mises theory were there good arguments
against his point or were there or were
those objections swift and emotional
responses from fearful would-be
administrators of the planned economy I
don't think the you know the I don't
think the individuals were important to
either to Mises or indeed to the those
individuals the individuals didn't read
von Mises and von Mises made no attempt
to popularize his theory or very little
attempt this was an academic thing so as
far as he was concerned and by the way
if you read one book its socialism by
von Mises where he explains that the
border between the free market and
tyranny and socialism started as soon as
government started to intervene in it
sure I'm sure that the people who would
get fired maybe accept that what we know
have been about government is however
much you cut it it's the benefits
there's all sorts of things that go but
the people who actually run it on the
whole don't get fired so it's it's not
easier Mises wasn't in the real world
actually and so your sort of question
which is immensely practical and a good
one I don't think he would have met many
Treasury officials I mean he himself was
well of course I shouldn't I should have
said that respond Mises was employed by
the state and then employed by American
universities for his whole life
Friedrich Hayek never got a private
sector job in the whole of his long life
he made a fortune out of the road to
serfdom which he wasted mostly on a
first wife who he left who he left on
Boxing Day with three young children in
order to marry his childhood sweetheart
because he made an error 20 years before
he ended up for Hayek he tried to get a
job at Chicago in the Economics
Department Friedman stopped him going
there
said it wasn't the sort of economist we
needed instead he had to have a sort of
second-rate job in a social science
department
he made no money in his life he didn't
even prepare for his old age he had to
sell his books to a German university
then he had to move to Germany in order
to be able to use his own books before
shortly after that he died so actually
the life of high occurs someone who was
surprised at sector operator really
doesn't come come about at all I do
mention here that he got very close to
doing some proper private sector work
when he came on a one-way ticket to
study at NYU the professor had gone out
to the Hamptons for the weekend and so
he was sort of stuck with no money no
cash at all and he went into a cafe and
said if he got any jobs and they said
he'd come back at six o'clock even wash
the dishes
happily for Hayek the professor arrived
about quarter to 6:00 so he didn't get
his hands sofie's at all so that saved
from that meanwhile this is one of these
and paradoxes which were the the key to
good storytelling really is that Keynes
who people described as the socialist
was never anything of the sort he wasn't
even a member of the Labour Party in
Britain and labor parties hardly
socialist he was always a lifelong
liberal he also was a master at
manipulating the market he used to say
this is a job I'm looking for he used to
say in his bed till noon on the
telephone as he called up his brokers
selling mostly currencies during the 20s
he lost a lot in 1929 but then he made
it all back within a year and a half and
more he was a master money maker the
Bloomsbury group that you will know
about artists poets novelists and so on
the reason that they were able to pursue
their artistic endeavors was because
Keynes looked after their little trust
funds than their parents are provided
with so they didn't have to do any
normal work if you like in the life tour
they could be in purely aesthetic it's a
it's an extraordinary story Akane's he
live
more than one life and it's not really
fair to joy you know to pin him up with
Hayek I mean very few people could it's
bit like Churchill than anybody you know
it's very difficult to to counter them
so thank you I'm going to or simplify
things a bit I think but my
understanding is the Austrian school has
never been implemented by any country
whereas Keynes has taken over since the
war and I just wonder if the politicians
look at the Austrian school as totally
free-market devoid of government
intervention then what would a president
do what would the Federal Reserve do of
me they wouldn't have a job does that
play into any of the thing you race it
without your say is fascinating and it
raises so many important points
well it's truth to say that if you
didn't have if you didn't waste any
money on government you wouldn't waste
any money on the House of
Representatives or the Senate or the
presidency so you might you might remove
democracy altogether if you leave it all
for them later Hayek was a great one for
saying I mean Hayek was never political
you know he he castigated Friedman who
went to work for Richard Nixon he said
you shouldn't do that you should never
mix with these people you know don't you
know this is bad they just give to give
them the plan and let them mess it up
but him I don't get involved yourself
and that's sort of true the the
implications of the Austrian school
could be immensely traumatic if you had
to balance the books
you know what Dettol got 1.2 trillion
and well if we even if you did that over
the course of 10 years considering that
there's very little discretionary
spending left in the system you'd either
have to cut drastically Social Security
or defense or Medicare
I can't see any notwithstanding the
present president-elect I can't see
anyone quite brave enough to take that
on what's more I mean Keynes was right
in as much as if you've borrowed 1.2
trillion that money is in the system and
if you take it out of the system you're
going to get a depression of some large
size so the Austrian school I think is a
what what I acted in the Mont Pelerin
Society wish to say what we need is a
goal we need a mission we need a way
forward we need something that all
conservatives on maybe libertarians too
would have to march in step just as the
left has over it's sort of socialistic
utopia but as for being practical I'm
not sure I mean he was in favor of no
borders at all I mean the free movement
of labour he wanted free movement we
accept that you know he wouldn't build
the wall you'd knock it down you know he
was interested in the removal of
democracy from cities for instance that
is if a private company wants to run a
city as a like a Gaugin biker sort of
big style gated community then that'd be
fascinating and if you didn't like
living in your city because it didn't do
what you wanted you just get in your car
and you move to the next privately-owned
city that did the same thing it it's
great in utopian terms to disseminate
stretches the brain to think about
moving privatisation into everything and
for that we should be most grateful
because he's stretched our brains and he
stretched what's possible but I don't
think ever he quite thought that it
would it was a sort of practical roadmap
where as Keynes was quite the other
thing he started off with a problem mass
unemployment and tried to work out how
to fix it now if the tools with which he
fixed it weren't entirely appropriate he
did for at least three decades if not
four decades after World War two and
during World War two
'we provide extraordinary numbers of
jobs and prosperity to a lot of people
you know you might be right for the
wrong reasons and Hayek might be wrong
for the right reasons but either way I
think that the Austrian school I'd never
seen anyone seriously say we should put
this into effect and you should beware
by the way people like Paul Ryan who say
and Hayekian because in the next breath
he says I'm an Indian and Rand spat at
kyuk at parties constantly accused him
of being a renegade and the selling outs
and so on the when you get into that
stuff it's it can be pretty tough and
anybody who says I agree with all these
things they haven't read the books
because she can't agree even if you said
I'm a Hayekian you're in trouble because
he contradicted himself too I mean
if you live that long and you write that
much you know things are gonna go wrong
but hey you're still better off reading
some Hayek than you are almost anyone
else just in terms of stretching your
brain we have time for one more question
okay you mentioned that I drew the line
on how much of the government should
intervene on housing food clothing
medical services where would you say a
Mises drew the line on that I wish I
knew more about Mises that we need to
Israel back to tell you because I just
honestly just don't know the answer to
that he came out of the same sort of
society though in embracing society and
I think that that in his germanic as
well as austrian but the sense that
actually the state should be coherent
and look after its citizens is strongly
felt and remains today it was strongly
felt during Nazi Germany to
so you know you ask mrs. Merkel as far
as she's concerned everybody should be
in a geographer which to have a home and
so on and it's a it's it's not a party
divided in that sense that whether Mises
actually put it as clearly as Hayek put
it in red serfdom I don't know I mean
it's interesting that Hayek of course
never referred to it again even though
he was constantly being badgered by
people saying but how do you do all this
you know why do why didn't you get
welfare dependency all the other things
that we know could happen if you look
after people a little too comfortably so
I don't know we must write a note to
Israel he'll tell you thank you thank
you very much
[Applause]